hello everyone and welcome to a
beautiful game that was played in round
8 of the Croatian championship a few
days ago it's a game between Sasha
Martina witch and the Zoran Ivanovich
Croatian grandmasters and it's really a
wonderful game it's a game that won the
brilliant surprise even though there is
no official brilliant surprise now as
the story goes I was contacted by a by a
gentleman of other caricature well known
figure in the chess world and he said
that he would like to raise some money
to be awarded as sort of a brilliancy
prize for the best game and that if I
would like I can also be on the
committee that will be choosing the the
most beautiful game I'd find that they
offer to be on the committee but I was
very interested in such such a thing
happening as the brilliancy prizes no
longer exist
I mean they don't in major tournaments
maybe somewhere there there is a prize
for the most beautiful game but you know
in bigger tournaments not really so I
was really interested in this and I said
that I'm you know sure that they are
more more than capable of choosing the
the the best game for me to show and
even though there are 11 rounds it was a
12 player single round-robin only games
from the first 10 rounds are among those
that they were choosing from so they
would have enough time to choose one but
even though the the championship
finished and there was a really really
nice game from the final round I will be
showing that tomorrow but for this game
really a beauty a cup of Blanca like
Beauty if you will but you'll get will
get back to that the price was pretty
much symbolic 1,001 Croatian Kuna that's
you know by today's standards I believe
that's somewhere around a hundred and
fifty dollars so nothing spectacular but
also you know it means a lot if you've
played the greatest game in the
championship but ok without further ado
let's check out the game and for those
of you who are interested in joining my
tournament later we'll have a nice
stream and Eisley chess tournament the
link in the description below the first
one will take you to that tournament so
let's check out the game
Sasha Martina which versus Zoran
Ivanovich Martina which opens with
d4 so the Queen's pawn opening we have
d6 by Black Knight to f3
six and now through a bit of a different
move order Martin which plays p4 and we
entered the pits defense nice to have
six going after d4 pawn of course white
will defend it nice to see three c6 and
now Bishop to e3 a pretty standard line
of the Pierce Queen to a5 now and here
Bishop to d3 by white and this position
has been reached plenty of times one of
the more notable games is again from
2003 gothic as part of vs. zurab as my
parish really where if I was played and
the ozma parish really was able to draw
this game against a Gary Kasparov but
here in this game we have Bishop to g7
bye-bye Ivanovich and it it's not a new
move but very few games have been played
unknown move in this position was h3 but
here with Queen to d2 creating this
queen the battery with ideas of maybe
exchanging the dark square bishop it's
as a move seven that we have a
completely new game which is not very
often for the best defense in such an
early move Bishop to g4 hoping to win
the knight on f3 and the double wide
spawn so you will not be able to use the
D H and G point to bust open the King
side it is possible to go something like
Bishop to h6 and after black castles you
can exchange the bishops and go if I
immediately try to create something but
after characters and captures but you
can just go 97 and black exchanged a few
pieces the White King is still in the
center why why still didn't start any
sort of attack on the Kings side and
what should be very happy with with a
position like this so here Martina which
chooses a different line he goes Knight
to h4 he doesn't allow any exchange on
f3 and now he can start pushing the bush
of the back as it is pretty awkwardly
placed with f3 maybe g4 g 5 depending of
course on what black plays we have E 5
here and now h3 pushes the bishop back
push it back to e6 and now even f4 what
ideas of capturing on e5 and pushing f5
so how can black deal with this you
could go something like captures and
after Bishop characters just Castle but
then again white also has some very nice
options you can Castle kingside you can
push f5 next it's not all that clear how
black
continue this game so what would be very
happy with this so instead after f4 we
have Knight to h5 now the bishop also
helps out with the defense of the e5
pawn the night also pressures f4 so pawn
captures an f4 would win the dark square
Bishop if if White will ever capture so
now a lot of ideas for black - in this
position so first D characters on e5
first capturing and only then pushing f5
and f5
if you trade captures captures you have
to move the bishop let's say Bishop b5
but now White has this excellent option
of going f6 just freeing up the f5
Square for the White Knight and after
black recaptures Knight f5 will be very
annoying for black you can't really
develop nicely you you want to go Knight
d7 and Castle maybe Queen side but you
still have to deal with your dark square
Bishop weakness here you you don't want
to castle them like why it's just gonna
castle capture and go Bishop h6 you know
Castle Kings that bring the rook into
the attack not all that good for black
and there's really not all that much you
could go Bishop f8 but again white will
just cast on now we have a weak knight
on f6 and your king is still stuck in
the center while white is mounting up
the attack
so after f5 the black didn't decide to
capture black played Bishop to f6 what
ideas okay you capture my Bishop I'll
capture your night Martina which castles
here he offers up the knight on h4 but
you know he will get an open F file for
his rook which is much more important
and also capture back the piece so
Bishop captures on h4 we have pawn
captures on e 6f captures on e6 and now
comes look a to d1 a silent but deadly
move as this rook controls the entire F
file now by playing rook e8 2 d1 the
Queen rook battery also not controls the
d5 and it's very hard for black to
decide what to do here you can easily
imagine if this Bishop wasn't here then
something like Queen here and then maybe
if the Queen moves from this diagonal it
could go something like Queen here Queen
to f7 could be checkmate and the black
King King is still in the center and
it's not all that easy to castle so here
you could go Queen c7 bring the Queen
back that way but like decides to go
Queen
to be four he wants to bring the Queen
over to e7 so it doesn't really matter
how you do it
and here you could try a lot of
different things for example if you
you could try Bishop to c4 and now the
Queen and the rook along the F file are
really pressuring blacks King side and
you have to go Queen back to e7 and it's
just gonna be a very tough position for
black to play but still if you capture
them we enter this line that we already
explained Queen d6 Queen c7 to f7
checkmate is the idea and if black tries
to prevent it let's see there should be
seven you get Queen c7 now with ideas of
Queen to c8 and not a lot you can do
here if you move the knight you no
longer control the d7 squares of Queen
to d7 will be checkmate just a lot of
checkmating possibilities for white so
here Martino didn't go for something
like Bishop to c4 although it's a very
nice move he played an even better move
which you are more than welcome to pause
the video and find it's just a very nice
idea that takes advantage of the black
Kings still being stuck in the center of
the awkward position of the black Queen
maybe that's why we need to c7 was a bit
better but feel free to pause the video
and try to find the move Martine which
played in this position for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are really an excellent tactician
and for those who just wanna enjoy the
show nice the b5 this is the move and
already you can see some threats here
tonight the c7 check winning the rook
here as you know it's a very nice fork
and also just Queen captures Queen so
two threads black has to deal with and
it's not all that easy to do it it's
interesting if you go back if you don't
trade Queens if you go Queen e7 where
ideas of guarding the c7 square then
Queen c3 is deadly
Weiss Queen C three deadly because black
doesn't really have a good move you're
threatening to capture here you're
threatening
after you win is to go ninety six check
you can do some discoveries with the
bishop but also if just pawn captures
knight then you get Queen c8 check and
there's really no good defense here if
you go if you walk with the Queen then
you get this nice check opening up a
discovery towards the black queen and
now after you blow up check just capture
scatters and now white can play whatever
once let you capture here Queens seven
blocks Queen captures on c6 with check
rooks are still controlling controlling
both the F and the D file the King has
nowhere to go you have to block with the
Queen and then just Queen captures is
checkmate
so after Knight to b5 your honor you
decided okay I will capture the Queen
with Queen captures but now not
automatically recapturing but instead a
nice in-between move a nice situation
zhuge Knights the d6 check so what do
you play here in the game King to d8 was
played
you might think okay but if my queen is
lost on the next move don't I wanna
capture the night why not Queen King t7
and then after he grabs my queen I'm
just gonna win a piece here the problem
is that's true but what's even gonna
force you to win his piece and now force
your King over to d6 and now after rook
captures and d2 there is no good defense
after this bishop moves it's checkmate
the King has nowhere to go all of these
squares are covered even if you push
something like c5 to make room for the
King doesn't really matter but b5 is
checkmate as bishop now covers the c6
square so you really have to be careful
and there isn't really a good defense if
you go Knight afford to block with the
night it is possible but then just
Bishop to a6 check will win you the rook
you have to block with the night and
then just Bishop captures b7 you'll win
the exchange you'll win your piece back
you will have a nice winning game so
that's why you don't go after the night
you want to play King to d8 but not just
rook capture some b2 White's idea is to
bring the knight the rook over to f7 and
there's no good way for for black to
prevent it
here black tried Knight to d7 you want
to get the King to c7 and try and get
your other look into the game but loop
to f7 white is extremely fast here we
have King to c7 getting the rook hard
way and well sort of pressuring the
knight but Bishop to c4 the rook now
defends the night and also Bishop
captures on e6 is the threat and there's
no way to prevent it you can go Knight
here as the regards that Square you can
bring the rook over here to protect the
pawn as the night covers that Square as
well so here Knight to f6 just trying to
activate pieces but again white is just
too fast
first better captures here putting a lot
of pressure
towards the night on b7 rook a to d8
defending the night and now once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the best way to continue this
attack for white and think of
yesterday's game and we caught outplayed
and the move he found to Tory maneuver
the night
once again I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
displacer of bishops and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
pawn to g3 a similar to Todd's move
yesterday where he displaced the
opponent's bishop to gain control of the
c3 square here g3 is played with a
similar idea you want to gain control of
the g5 Square to attack the knight at to
pin it as the rook is behind the knight
and to threaten to capture it as this
potent knight is pinned of course you
will not be able to capture back so here
there is no better move you can go back
to g5 pawn capture the Bishop captures
and g3 was played and here of course
just Bishop to g5 as you have now won 2g
v square and here there is no good move
for black black try to look D to F 8
hoping to trade some material but it is
far too late
just Bishop captures on f6 the knight
cannot recapture as it spins so first
the rook captures rook
no the knight is no longer pinned but
white gets a move as well we have Knight
captures on f7 which idea of capturing
the rook but still doesn't matter what
white plays it's a world black place
it's all over Knight captures here was
played and here after Knight chapters on
h8 Zoran Ivanovich resigned to the game
unmoved 26 I don't know it would be a
little bit better if you resigned here
so it would be a 25 more victory which
today is really considered like a
miniature but still ok captures captures
and it's a 26 move miniature but still
we can agree it's a miniature because
black was lost for for such a long time
that it's just a just a beautiful game I
really I don't know I said it was like a
cup of Blanca like game because the wife
played really really simple but really
the strongest and there was nothing
black could do so I really hope you
liked it and you know that it justifies
the the brilliant surprise it's one in
the Croatian championship not
official brilliant surprise but you know
the the the manufactured one so to say
but in a really nice game I really
enjoyed it a lot to learn from it so I
do hope you enjoyed it as well like I
said the first thing in the description
below will be a link to enter the
delicious arena will be having to
commemorate the 400,000 subscriber
milestone so I do hope a lot of you can
join the live stream and the tournament
and yeah I would like to thank you lea
kabocha which michael everett matthew
sobbing edwin McCarty and under the RO
aho Jorge for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon well with the incoming
stream and tomorrow I probably will
check the the last game from the
tournament coral vs both co2 - really
really a wonderful game and then most
likely continuing the Capablanca saga up
until the the Greinke chest classic and
then after that hopefully finishing the
capablanca saga so we can start some
other sagas hopefully I will yeah thank
you all I will see you soon have an
excellent rest of your Friday